good evening I'm Stuart bran from the
long now foundation how many were at
Friday night's to do with that Wilson my
god look at this
okay it's been biology week and it's
going to keep being biology week I think
a peculiarity of these long now is talks
is that so many of them wind up being
whole earth ish Edie was what was
subject of his book the social
domination of Earth sulfa conquest of
Earth and then we had mark Lynas talking
about the Anthropocene basically the
nine barriers that basically could limit
human and other life on this planet that
humans have somewhat over done planet
planet planet holder fourth and here
comes Charles C man who limited himself
to the Americas the last time with 1491
just two years later suddenly he's whole
earth 1493 and it's the homogeneous
scene this time let's travel with him
Charles see me
[Applause]
thank you can you hear me this is all
working right I thought I'd start at the
beginning as many of you probably
learned in school 200 million years ago
the earth consisted of a single giant
landmass scientists call Pangaea
geological forces broke it up forever
separating the continents and for our
surfer ever separating the inhabitants
of those continents creating completely
separate ecosystems that effectively
didn't touch each other for tens of
millions of years
completely different Suites of plants
and animals that about 500 years ago
were suddenly brought together by this
guy one of the ways I got started in
this whole subject was about 15 years
ago my parents demanded that I come back
to my childhood home and clear out the
stuff that I'd left there since I'd gone
to college any of you her parents will
recognize the kind of waiver child that
I was and I opened up all the boxes of
junk that I'd had in the attic and I
discovered to my chagrin my 8th grade
American history textbook from Highland
junior high school which I had never
returned and right in the front was this
picture here of Christopher Columbus and
I stared at it kinda riveted because as
I looked at it I realized that there
were many things that were wrong with
this picture and not just the fact that
everybody and it looks like George
Washington from a modern perspective
well we recognize about Columbus is that
he and the people who came over with him
we're not alone in those ships
this picture shows basically nothing but
people but in fact huge numbers of
passengers went on the ships of Columbus
and his successors and so a more
realistic picture would look something
like this because Columbus inaugurated
what the wonderful historian Alfred
Crosby is called the Columbian Exchange
which was this period of time that we
still live in today where huge numbers
of creatures from over there came over
here huge numbers of creatures from over
here came over there it was the biggest
ecological convulsion since the death of
the dinosaurs and it shapes human
history as well from biological point of
view however
this could be said not just to be an
exchange the kind of thing that I've
been talking about in human history but
something that they've called the
homogeneous een and it comes from the
idea that the earth ecosystems are being
put in a blender and homogenized and as
I also like the idea that it comes from
homogeneous you know man
human generated the term was coined by
Michael Sam ways and you know has been
abused by me for a few years now but the
idea said this is this period that we we
live in now it's the beginning of
globalization it all starts with
Columbus and its import is as much
ecological as it is economic and one way
to think about it is shown here this is
a Dutch genre painting there's many of
these kind of paintings and what they
effectively show is lower middle class
people living in barns and this is the
way the countless numbers of people in
Europe Asia and Africa live for
thousands of years after agriculture and
there's sitting there surrounded by
their domestic animals now the reason
that this is important is that as we
know from things like bird flu every now
and then a human disease becomes excuse
me an animal disease jumps to species
barrier as scientists say and becomes a
human disease and so from an
epidemiologist point this is what the
picture looks like so here you have the
cow you know which is the source of
bovine rinderpest which is an ancestor
of measles and tuberculosis
you have the poultry which we know from
influenza also whooping cough or
pertussis the horse in the background
there is a Quine encephalitis and
probably smallpox then up in the rafters
here you have bats which are the source
of rabies and so huge numbers of people
in Europe Asia and Africa spent their
lives swimming in a kind of bacterial
and viral soup all day all their lives
and this was a major factor in the way
that they lived now let's go to the
Americas you know before Columbus in
this period of time when there was no
contact and you see here a typical
Powhatan longhouse the Powhatan were the
people that were encountered by John
Smith's and those people in Chesapeake
Bay in the 1600s and so if you're an
architect you look at this house and say
it's essentially the same as the barn we
saw in the previous picture it's a straw
sure held up by Timbers lashed together
there's no windows there's no chimney
it's effectively the same building the
big difference here is that every animal
in the picture is dead
it's like Sarah Palin's dream house it's
and the reason for this is that by a
quirk of evolutionary history that we
can talk about if you're curious it's to
learn more about it that at the time of
Columbus there were very very few
domesticable animals in the Americas
there no cattle there no horses there
all sheep there are no goats there's no
poultry there's none of the familiar
domestic animals nor any analogues to
them and so the peoples of the Americas
did not spend their time swimming in
this kind of bacterial and viral soup
there's an enormous difference there and
so in the first hundred and fifty years
or so after Columbus the big party
exchange was invisible these
microorganisms and on the right hand
side of this picture here is a partial
list of the organisms that crossed the
Atlantic from Europe to the Americas in
the first hundred and fifty years and on
the left-hand side is a pretty complete
list of the ones who went the other way
and this enormous epidemiological
imbalance I would argue it's the most
important fact that your kids should
probably learn about American history
since Columbus because when these
diseases came you know imported
inadvertently by Europeans in the first
hundred and 150 years after Columbus the
result was that somewhere between
two-thirds and 95% of the original
inhabitants of the Americas died it was
the greatest demographic catastrophe in
human history there's been nothing like
it before or after thank God and it was
an absolutely extraordinary event that
goes a tremendously long way towards
explaining why small groups of poorly
Sapa poorly equipped Europeans at the
ends of very long supply chains were
able to establish themselves in
ecosystems they were utterly unlike
anything that they had seen before
absent this mammoth exchange of mammoths
in one sided exchange of microorganisms
it's very difficult to understand how my
ancestors and many of the ancestors and
people in this room would have got here
now this it wasn't the only impact that
had on the human world one of the
pleasures of working on this book that I
recently pub
was that a little bit of it appeared in
National Geographic and I got to work
with a wonderful illustration and map
staff there and we contacted about you
know 20 or so anthropologists
archaeologists and ecologists who work
on you know the history of the
landscapes of the eastern seaboard and
we asked them what you know the area
that they studied look like in you know
at Columbus time in 1500 and we put
their answers together and compiled this
map now this isn't like to be understood
as some perfect pixel-by-pixel
recreation it's an indicative map and we
were trying to show is that the human
imprint on the east coast of the
Americas was extremely heavy all these
areas that are lighter green were
cleared by fire for agriculture and even
the areas that we show forests most of
them were open by today's standards
because native people burn the
undergrowth every year to encourage the
kind of tender new shoots that would
bring in the kind of game that they like
to hunt and so in fact the forests were
so open and park-like that people like
John Smith reported being able to ride
it at a full gallop through the through
the woods and he was crazy enough that
he might have actually have done it so
you have the landscape that looks like
this then very quickly after Columbus
all the people were maintaining this
landscape died and the result is a
mammoth reforestation of the Lant
landscape the first impact of Europeans
on the Americas because this is repeated
throughout the Americas is this huge
reforestation and the wilderness that is
celebrated by throw and John Muir and
people like that was largely inadvertent
European creation and a lot of media
people don't have the same feelings
about it because for them it's a
cemetery and so this picture that we
have you know that I certainly grew up
with of this sort of Pat you know
trackless forest and in my that same
eighth grade American history textbook
talks about how a squirrel could go from
tree to tree to tree all the way from
Cape Cod to the Mississippi River you
know that image that we have the great
American wilderness dates back from this
time and it was something that my
ancestors saw and when they came here in
the 18th century
did but they didn't realize that it was
in fact a recent phenomenon now if you
think about it when you look at this
kind of phenomena what are these the
cessation of fires the regrowth of trees
what you're talking about is a dramatic
drop of carbon of carbon levels in the
air and so in recent years and you know
lots of scientific papers appeared that
have this kind of incomprehensible
looking graph and the point here is not
to try and have you understand this
graph because it is kind of
incomprehensible but to try to convince
you that these kinds of graphs exist and
what they are are researchers attempting
to measure the carbon levels you know
carbon dioxide levels in the air 500
years ago and what they typically show
is that they plummet right after
Columbus carbon dioxide levels plummet
and you can see it in you know lots of
different measures like the little
bubbles of gas trapped in Arctic ice
which can be red and kind of like tree
rings because it get built up every year
it's done and the bottom and here of
Central American lakes it's also done by
tree growth records and you know isotope
counts and there's all these kinds of
things that suggests that there's this
huge down drop in the level of carbon
dioxide in the air and this is the I
think the leading theory an explanation
for a period of time called the Little
Ice Age which is about a 250 year cold
snap that begins in about 1550 and ends
in about 1800 causes no very very cold
temperatures throughout the northern
hemisphere for that 250 year period and
ends up in the creation of yet another
Dutch genre painting style and what it
is of the little kids skating on the
canals and I love I love this picture
and I read an entire extremely dull
biography of Pieter Bruegel service I
performed for you to try and find out
when he actually painted it and about
after 350 turgid pages I discovered that
this had actually been painted in late
April and early May if any of you have
been to the Netherlands it's been a very
long time since the Netherlands looked
like this in April in May and so what
you're seeing here then in this kind of
you know shinbone connected to the knee
bone connected to the ankle bone or what
way is the
kind of back and forth crosscurrents you
know around the world that lead you know
me and I would argue many more
increasingly most historians to say that
this period of globalization this period
of time when one part of the world is
all mixed up with another part of the
world really begins with Columbus and
ends up being as much ecological as
economic now none of our ancestors none
of the Europeans involved nor none of
the Native people actually thought about
things in this term this is a modern
attempt to impose some kind of order on
the past what they were thinking about
was shown here and for their from their
point of view the most important event
after Columbus what is shown here which
is when in southern bolivia the
spaniards discovered potosi which is the
biggest silver strike in history by a
huge margin and it was as essentially as
close to a mountain of pure silver as
geology allows it was just a vast
expansion in the world's money supply
because most of the world used silver
for money supply the world supply of
precious metals doubled or even tripled
in the you know century or so after the
discovery of potosi and from the
europeans point of view what happened is
this gush silver washed in there kind of
like The Beverly Hillbillies before
Western Europe had been relatively poor
part of the world suddenly this vast sum
of money just sort of throws in their
laps and they begin to be able to throw
their their weight around and so you
know like anybody who's just had a
windfall what the Europeans do is go
shopping and so they get the silver here
a bunch of it crosses the the Pacific to
Spain's outpost in Manila which is
established in 1571 and then they bring
silk porcelain slaves and spices over
here to Mexico add you know tobacco and
sugar and so forth ends up in Spain they
used by guns and horses which used if we
get to slaves which are used to mine the
silver and so you have this loop of
commerce that involves every habitable
part of the ocean starting in the 16th
century and in fact at one point my
editor suggested that my book should be
called ha ha
Tom Friedman the world has been flat for
400 years but
we decided that this wasn't actually
that commercial and so we we are stuck
with 1493 but again the impact from you
know as we think of it now was you know
as much more ecological than economic
because on those ships came huge numbers
of organisms and that had this enormous
effect and one of the most important
from the European point of view is the
potato these are what actually potatoes
look like if you go to small villages in
the Andes they've been developed there
for thousands of years and the Andes
you know they grow potatoes in every
conceivable ecological notion for every
conceivable taste there's almost 6000
known varieties that are in the
International potato center in Lima and
you know the first time I saw this kind
of thing I was in a small town in the
Andes and I saw these strange-looking
objects and so I said to the you know
people selling him what are you selling
and they said potatoes and I said no no
those things over there what are those
potatoes and I felt like what are they
doing spoofing the gringo and I said no
no what are those and finally I got
through my thick head that they were
potatoes and that my idea of the potato
was from their point of view woefully
unimaginative so this tiny slice of the
available selection of potatoes makes
its way to Europe and after a period of
resistance because Europeans don't grow
tubers and they don't you know in this
way and they don't really understand how
they how they work they are adopted now
I should tell you a little bit about the
way the potatoes are grown in the Andes
because they're grown in this kind of
Ridge and furrow system and the so that
people plant the you know carve the land
into these ridges and furrows and plant
the potatoes on top of the the ridges
and the reason for doing this you can
see here the ridges it's even though
it's just you know this much difference
between the top and the bottom the
ridges are substantially warmer than the
then the furrows and you know obviously
high up in the Andes that makes a big
difference but also they're
substantially drier and so you can see
here you know in this snowfall and
potato season that the tops are you know
considerably less snow considerably
drier than the ridges and furrows and
turns out that this is that if you want
to grow potatoes a big problem with them
is fungus type diseases and they'd
funguses don't like warm dry areas they
prefer cool wet areas
and so this way of growing it turns out
to be a pretty good way of preventing
fungi now Europeans again don't really
know about this what they do know is
shown here if you're growing wheat you
know the traditional European crop if
you look at the wheat here it's got this
you know big head and this skinny little
stem so if you're a particularly
successful wheat farmer and you have
lots and lots of grain on each stem the
plants will fall over because they get
top-heavy and this is called lodging and
will kill the plant and so you're
punished in a certain sense if you're
too successful now over here you have a
very happy lebanese farmer for about two
thousand eight and i don't think that's
a photographic trick i think it is
actually live this potato is actually
bigger than his head and it's about a 25
pound potato and the reason that you can
go potato can be just as big as you want
because it's underground in the
architecture of the plant doesn't cause
any problems and so records suggest that
europeans when the potato comes grow
about four times as much dry food matter
as scientists say you know taking out
the water and all that sort of thing as
from an acre of potatoes that you get
from an acre of wheat and so this huge
band of europe between the ukraine and
ireland becomes andean eyes they start
growing potatoes and in began they get
this massive increase in the supply of
food and so you you know up until the
early 20th century you would see these
exact same ridges and furrows but they
became increasingly rare because the
agricultural reformers and great
rationalists became convinced that this
was wasteful in what you needed to do is
just grow you know flat areas of
potatoes and this is something i'm gonna
bring up later so you have i hope in
mind this enormous belt of europe
growing all these potatoes and becoming
much more well-fed than ever before and
this is the effects of this has shown
the great french historian for nampara
del was the first to really talk about
this and he compiled both the records of
numbers have sort of Europe wide famines
and what you see is that when the potato
comes these things just drop off the
face of the face of the earth because
there's just more food available and
then you also see a big kick up
in the number of Europeans increasingly
historians recognize that the potato
essentially is the fuel for Empire
without that you know the the before the
potato is introduced European history
sort of lurches from one food crisis to
the next there's in France for example
in the in the 17th century there's one
nationwide famine more than one per
decade in the hundreds and hundreds of
local famines there's bread riots
there's you know people milling around
in starving constantly there's you know
there's state granaries that always have
armed guards on its place a mess potato
comes and pretty much all of this stops
and population begins to boom so the
government's because they're not dealing
with bread riots become much more stable
and they have a larger supply of
Europeans so it's games go send them off
to foreign places to conquer things and
so you know it's very difficult to
understand these European empires that
grow up in the late 18th and 19th
century without understanding the potato
and in fact I would argue if you happen
to be going to you know book sink or you
know one of the fine book stores in San
Francisco and in search of a one-volume
history of Europe you should flip
through the index and if you don't see
an entry for potato put the book back
and look for a more modern book now the
potato also becomes because it's this
new crop is growing this new way becomes
a target for agricultural reformers in
the great you know thinkers of the
Enlightenment people were these names
that to person my generation sounds
strange like Jethro Tull who turns out
to be this important agricultural
reformer I thought it was like something
they had made up and one of the things
that they understand in the early 19th
century is the role of nitrogen the
plants depend on nitrogen if you want to
have huge yields you have to get
nitrogen in a particular types of what
they call bioavailable forms forms that
the plants can digest and it turns out
that there are these islands off the
coast of Peru where sea birds have
roosted for Sentret for millennia upon
millennia and have created these huge
cliffs mounds of of guano which turns
out to be excellent fertilizer and so
the in the middle of the nineteenth
century they start bringing over Chinese
slaves and setting up
waa no mines and filling ships full of
guano and taking them to Europe and the
first big shipments begin in 1843 where
they've you know large numbers of you
see this is the beginning of modern
input intensive agriculture the kind of
thing that there's an entire industry of
writers who rail against many of them
here in San Francisco so I think you
know what I'm talking about this this
idea of treating the land is a kind of
petri dish and and so it all begins here
with a potato and with guano and so if
you're a modern American farmer in the
nineteenth century
you bought things like this we and would
sprinkle it on and you have these your
soil and you would have these magical
results now these guano ships carried
though as far as we can determine a
second hidden passenger fatah fur
infestans the potato late blight which
is a water mold it basically it looks
like a fungus oh it's not you know from
taxonomically a fungus and basically it
really really likes to eat potatoes and
it's very very good at it
and then you see the first sort of
modern agricultural catastrophe it's
first reported here at the end of June
1845 and you can see the ripples
spreading out and basically over a
period of a couple months it goes all
the way across Europe and wipes out the
entire potato crop now because potatoes
have become so productive people in
Europe are now very very dependent on
the potato and no one is more dependent
on the potato than the Irish about 40%
of the Irish eat literally no solid food
other than potatoes the result is that
in a few weeks you know the entire food
supply for these 40% of the Irish
disappear and it's a you know it's just
a catastrophe
beyond imagining about 2 million people
died 1 million of them alone of them in
Ireland and there's the ships full of
half-starved refugees who go across the
the the Atlantic and land in places like
Boston and Quebec leaving a trail of
dead behind them is just you know
absolutely horrible
this is the last famine that occurred
before the widespread use of modern
photography so we don't have any
photographic images of it but
newspapers are full of these kind of
drawings gives you some idea of of what
it was like in Ireland from a biological
point of view or what we're learning is
that as creatures come over there's this
phenomenon called ecological release
which is they are transported from one
place to another often the pests and
pathogens that like to eat them are not
transported along with them they
flourish they do exceptionally well this
is what happened with the potato but
nature has a way of closing the loop and
in this case it closed the loop with cut
to catastrophic effect now this wasn't
just something that happened in Europe
it also these impacts or if anything
were even larger in China now when I
went to Highland junior high school we
didn't learn anything about China or
anything about geography at all so in
case some of you went to my kind of high
school I thought I would show you a map
of China and here it is and one of the
things you'll notice about China here is
all this parts of China here that
there's no River the China has no Bott
large bodies of water whatsoever right
there's no great lakes in China and that
there's only these two rivers of any
size the the Yangtze in the Hawaiian kr
Yellow River and most of the course that
they go through are these very dry steep
hills which aren't really suitable for
agricultural so there's only two small
areas of China There Were Watching where
there's large amounts of flat well
watered agricultural land and this is
the sort of central dilemma of Chinese
history that you know his beset Emperor
after emptor dynasty after dynasty that
you have 20 percent of the world's
population 7 percent of the world's
freshwater and what is the staple food
that you really like to grow it's rice
which has to be grown in swimming pools
and so you you know which is you know a
colossal historical mistake because if
you have if you have a country that's
you know half desert the last thing you
want to do is have rice be your staple
crop now this all dramatically changes
in about 1600 when two American crops
come the sweet potato and maize or corn
as its called
in the States they're brought over from
Manila they come in actually into the
country in a couple of different ways
and the they are the first crops that
can be grown in relatively dry land and
they're really really you know
significant agricultural products that
produce a lot of a lot of calories and
so if you go to North West or Southwest
China today in these areas of desert you
see sites like this all over the place
and it's it's for me you know it's
totally weird their growth I mean this
looks like they're trying to farm a
beach and yet they managed to get
something out of it and so what you had
in China when these crops came in was
this massive westward movement as the
central government got people in from
the Han Chinese which is the sort of
main Chinese ethnic group the one that's
always you know when you refer to the
Chinese you're really forgetting to the
Han Chinese they go into the lightly
settled West where there's all these
ethnic groups that are not Han Chinese
the Han Chinese push them out and start
clearing these areas that haven't really
been farmed before and start planting
corn and sweet sweet potatoes and the
impact there is much like what happened
in in Europe they introduced American
crops mmm China population goes up and
this is where China really becomes a
watchword for population it's with the
the homogeny scene it's you know
creation of this exchange of plants and
animals around the world now the way
they do this in these very steep areas
again it goes right into the 20th
century that's why you're able to see
photographs like this goes right into
the Maya dynasty where they essentially
take a village and they say go out here
and Terrace this at unimaginable labor
and so there's these huge areas of China
where you have that you see this you
know wedding-cake effect and they're
growing potatoes sweet potatoes and
maize you know again American crops now
there's a drawback to doing this in
these in these areas and that there's
not that much stone
so all these terraces are made out of
dirt and if you stay in the villages in
a rains which it does occasionally
you're woken up at 4 o'clock in the
morning bike
and what it is is every person out there
is going out with hand tools and whack
and trying to whack the terraces back
into shape because they're falling down
all the time as you can imagine this
isn't the most effective procedure and
so this here is about a hundred year old
terrace where this poor bugger is still
trying to grow sweet potatoes now if
you're looking at this I hope you're
thinking we'll wait a minute what
happened to all the dirt that used to be
there from this from this Terrace and it
goes right down into the bottom of this
ravine here it's picked up in some
little creek nameless creek it's brought
down to a tributary of the in this case
the hwang hae and goes into the into the
gwanghae Yellow River now when you have
a whole lot of sediment eroded sediment
going into a river what happens is as
long as the river is going fast as long
as it's going down through all these
steep hills the churning of the river
keeps the sediment suspended but when it
goes into the flat areas like the North
China Plains you know the area that I
showed with the red circle around it
what happens is because it's flat the
river slows down the sediment starts
depositing starts going on the bottom of
the riverbed and because there's a lot
of it you have this curious phenomena
where the riverbed starts to build up
and sooner sooner rather than later
the riverbed starts to get higher than
the surrounding land and so there are
parts of China where the Yellow River is
40 feet above the surrounding farmland
now you don't have to be have a PhD in
physics to know it's not an especially
good idea to have a giant river 40 feet
in the air the result is as you will
I think imagine floods and one of the
things that we did is that when I went
to Beijing we found this book where the
Chinese state meteorological Bureau had
compiled all these records from counties
you know which is the sort of basic
these County gazetteers which were
required every year to fill in and send
to the imperial court and they did these
flood maps for six hundred years and I
sort of randomly picked one now this is
very hard to understand so what I've
done is doctored it up a little bit for
you and the way to think about it as was
explained to me it said see these areas
here these dark areas here this is where
the Saran
we chose in year 1823 they had like a
catastrophic Katrina type flood where
there was you know massive amounts of
water massive amounts of deaths you know
permanent destruction the entire village
is wiped out and then this band here is
where they had just sort of deadly
floods where like people's crops would
be wiped out or people would be
dispossessed but you didn't have you
know this appalling you know years long
devastation and this happened year after
year after year fed by you know the
erosion caused by the planting of these
American crops and so the way the state
meteorological Bureau guy explained it
to me he said just tell your American
audiences that it was like a Katrina per
month for a hundred years now as you can
imagine this didn't endear the Ching
dynasty the government at the time to
the people you know you're dealing with
millions upon millions of wandering
refugees starvation massive damage there
is a flood refugees caused something
called the Taiping rebellion where 20
million people died it was just China
was a total mess and this I would argue
goes a long way to explaining why in the
19th century after decades of this sort
of thing small groups of Europeans were
able to march in and throw their weight
around this is much to do with the with
the fall of China and so the same kind
of ecological swashing around the
homeland Jenna scene that was you know
gave Europe a big leg up gave stepped on
China for a while and to this day the
Chinese are still trying to recover from
the devastation wrought by the you know
sort of these introduction the American
crops this is the kind of thing that you
can do in a dictatorship now instead of
entire villages being told to go out and
you know Terrace they're told to level
the terraces and plant trees and so you
see this kind of site they dig their
coal fish-scale pits they dig them and
now that the villagers are rewarded by
the number of trees they plant not by
the number of trees they survive so that
you see miles and miles and miles of
dead trees because they grow northern
pine which are you know not
actually terribly suitable but we were
explained it was explained to me about
one of the villagers that this is
actually an okay system because if the
tree is dead then you don't have to dig
a new pit you just if you just put a new
tree in it it dies the next year and but
you've made your quota so you're okay so
I'm not really sure about how
efficacious this whole bit is but you
can see this and what this is all again
is trying to recover from the
introduction of the sweet potato and in
maize five hundred years ago now it
wasn't the same thing you know or
similar kinds of effects happened in the
Americas probably the most long-lasting
gift that Columbus gave to the Americans
with malaria now in case again any of
you went to my kind of high school I
should explain that malaria is a
single-celled parasite there's all
there's a whole slew of different types
but there's only a few that are
important to human beings all of them
are called Plasmodium and they the basic
deal is there's a type of mosquito genus
of mosquitoes called Anopheles that
exists you know most of the world that
can host these these single-celled
organisms they bite you they inject some
of these cells into your body they go
through a bunch of changes and they get
into a form where they can pry open red
blood cells and you know hide inside
them multiply like crazy and then in a
kind of a coordinated assault they rip
open billions of blood cells and flood
your body you feel awful you know awful
beyond imagining and while you're
wracked like this another mosquito bites
you there's so many of them in your
bloodstream it draws up a few and the
cycle begins anew and malaria is an
incredibly wily organism your immune
system will eventually if you survive
beat it off but it can actually hide in
your spleen or your liver for months or
even years in the end so it was quite
became quite possible for Europeans or
Africans to cross the Atlantic come here
and then suddenly get malaria and there
was already vectors as they call it
through mosquitoes again capable of
transforming so it came to the Americas
quite early now this is a map showing
some of the major types of Anopheles
mosquitoes their ranges so showing that
it was all over the place now the deal
is the worst kind of malaria is
falciparum malaria Plasmodium falciparum
and the it's a tropical beast and it
really really hates anything that smacks
of cold weather and so there's a range
in which it can exist and it's this is
roughly it in in North America it's
roughly the mason-dixon line
there are almost pretty exactly the
mason-dixon line it can it was malaria
was a constant problem in in Washington
DC but in southern New Jersey or
someplace like that it was just a rare
visitor same thing is true here you have
you know constant problem in southern
Brazil but in Ecuador and Argentina
it's an occasional visitor I'd also like
you to notice something I would argue is
not a coincidence that this area here is
the area in which slavery was a major
institution in the Americas the overlap
between the boundaries of malaria and
the and the boundaries of slavery is a
major institution in slave societies
it's really striking now I'd like you to
keep that in your heads for a moment and
show you a couple more maps now as you
probably you may have learned in school
malaria has been around so long that
different types of people in areas with
lots of malaria have evolved strategies
genetic strategies to try and combat the
disease the most faint and most of them
involve changing something about the red
blood cell to make it harder for the for
the Plasmodium to get in and replicate
inside and so the here is sickle cell
anemia which is a very complicated thing
but maybe a very simple way of saying it
sort of makes you half immune to
Plasmodium and as you'll see it's most
concentrated in central in West Africa
now this is another kind that's not
nearly as well known and it's called
it's also another way of changing the
the red blood cell this one has a couple
of bizarre side effects there's a little
bit of it it's not showing this map
that's in Sicily and there the result is
that there's a certain number of Italian
Americans who have this and one of the
side effects of this particular genetic
condition is a deadly allergy to fava
beans and so
you live in Italy every now and then
there are newspapers of carry a story
about some some poor guy who goes to you
know see his grandfather's town in in
Sicily
you know catches up with you know uncle
George oh and you know they're all
getting together they serve him a
platter of fava beans and he keels over
but it you know the Italians of course a
sidelight and so what you have here
again Central West Africa is where
people who have this form immunity
exists there's another type of malaria
called vivax malaria that's a second
most important this is a duffy-negative
antigen another red blood cell change
again Central and West Africa in fact
it's so prevalent in Central West Africa
that Central West Africa are the only
tropical places in the entire world
where vivax doesn't exist and finally as
a kind of kicker malaria is often
comforting by another disease yellow
fever which is kind of like chicken pox
it's a viral disease if you get it when
you're a kid you feel sick but you
survive you get it with an adult it's
about 75% mortality
it's also transmitted by a mosquito 80s
gypped I and the at the time of Columbus
the range of 80s Egypt I was here
which meant effectively that all Central
and West Africans got of his children
were immune so this was the greatest
pool of people who were immune to yellow
fever in in the world as well now the
difference between being immune to
yellow fever and malaria and not being
immune was first elucidated by the great
historian Philip Curtin he did
epidemiological research and what he
showed he did studies a British a
military personnel in various places
overseas and recorded simply how many of
them died and you know and what what was
their death rates and so if you go to
malaria areas like Sierra Leone or the
Cape Coast which is in both in West
Africa you see you have roughly between
you know between half and two-thirds of
all Europeans who the Brits who went
there you know in the in this time died
you know the every year so if you had a
hundred this is this is per thousand I
forgot to say so if you had a hundred
Europeans who show up in West Africa
they stay there for a year at the end of
the year
you know that most 50% will survive then
he compared it to Africans these are in
the same places and you see that 32 in
the in the case of West Africa and so
that's like a tenfold difference
Europeans are 10 times more likely to
die in places with malaria and yellow
fever than Africans this has a lot to do
I would argue with a question that was I
think first raised by Adam Smith in the
wealth of nations if you read the wealth
of nations there's four or five places
in it where he tries to wrestle with
slavery which he couldn't understand why
it existed and the reason he couldn't
understand why existed was first there
was an institution for getting labor in
places in northern Europe and it was
called the indentured servant and
indentured servants were in fact how
initially in the 16th in the early 17th
century most Europeans came to North
America you would sign you know you were
a tobacco farmer you would want to have
more labor to you know people to cut
your tobacco so you would go and find
some poor people in England you would
have them sign a contract you pay for
their passage which was very expensive
they would work for you for four to
seven years you know working off their
passage and then they would they would
then you have a chance to start their
own farm and as Smith noted this system
had worked very well in in Europe for
centuries why then was it supplanted by
this plantation slavery
especially given that Africans don't
speak the same language as Europeans
because they come from tropical areas
they don't farm the same kind of thing I
mean they don't farm annual crops in the
same way and they certainly don't farm
wheat and then of course they have no
interest in working because they're
slaves and they want to kill you if
anything they're like the world's worst
workers so why Smith said when you had a
perfectly reasonable institution did
this come to existence and if you read
The Wealth of Nations he basically comes
to no answer he's he's bringing it up
and then finally he saw rings his hand
and says well people are evil and that's
the reason and people may be evil but
it's not very satisfactory and I would
argue that once you did what Adam Smith
didn't understand was that
the home of Gena seen had occurred and
malaria had suddenly transported itself
to to the Americas and there there's a
tenfold more chance that your European
indentured servant is going to die than
in African slave and it's better to have
an unwilling rebellious worker than a
dead worker and that this puts a
tremendous thumb on the scale and has a
powerful explanatory effect about why
there is places like Massachusetts which
is the first state to explicitly
legalized slavery but is never really a
slave society and the same thing is true
for Argentina where they're slaves but
it's not a slave society when just over
you know a few hundred miles away the
same types of people are suddenly you
know involved in full-scale slave
societies like you see in Virginia and
the Carolinas in Brazil and this has an
impact not only just on our own history
because obviously slavery has a huge
impact you know American and world
history but it also has an impact on our
species itself before Columbus Europeans
were basically lived in Europe Africans
were to be found in Africa Native
Americans and Native America East Asians
in Asia and and so forth you know there
are very few people that were out of
place like this after Columbus you know
our own species is put in the blender
and you see strange things like European
domination in places like Australia New
Zealand and Argentina you see African
domination in places like Brazil and
China towns all over the globe
you know this tremendous shaking up of
our owns of our own species but the
dominating factor in this is the African
slave trade and as David elta Sydney
Murray University points out that when
you think of calling history we tend to
think of those guys like George
Washington you know with their wigs and
so forth but in fact nearly four times
as many Africans as Europeans came over
during the during this colonial period
and so what you really see from a point
of view of biology is you know a
diminishing native population and the
surging African population colliding
together throughout the Americas with
Europeans playing a demographically
peripheral role and so this is you know
the view of what actually is happening
and the result is again to create this
extraordinary mixing of cultures and
people's and the first ones is and this
is a drawing by my daughter right so I
hope you're enjoying it this is in
Mexico City which is the first really
21st century City it's the first place
where you have people from every corner
of the world together there's a big
Chinatown in the middle of the plaza may
or there's a this is the picture of the
Asian market there's nearly ten times as
many Africans and people of African
descent is there are Europeans there is
you know this is this extraordinary
melting pot and it's the kind of thing
that when you walk today in San
Francisco and you know of course San
Francisco is always praised for its you
know extraordinary diversity of cultures
what we're seeing is a kind of
replication of something that began in
Mexico City 400 years ago the first
truly modern metropolis and it can end
the condition that we are all
increasingly heading towards and again
it's something you know that's living in
the homogeneous scene who knows what's
gonna happen next
thank you very much for coming and
listening thank you to Stuart
thank you Kevin Kevin Lee thanks to our
friend Neil for bringing us together
[Applause]
let's go sit that was fast
I just felt 500 years ago buying a
border thank you so is it over is the
big mix finished now it's all the Majin
scene is one big now milkshake here I'll
give you an example I didn't talk about
actually this book you know if you want
to have an industrial revolution need
three things you need fossil fuels you
need steel and you need rubber and
fossil fuels pretty much everywhere
fortunately or unfortunately they're all
over the place
steel which some iron is all over the
place but the only place we can get
natural rubber is of good quality is
Brazil is the Amazon basin and so in
late nineteenth century there is an you
know kind of a rubber boom in the Amazon
there's you know extraordinary phenomena
like giant opera houses built in the
middle of the forest and and in this
kind of thing and there's a national
villain in Brazil a British guy named
Henry Wickham the inventor of biopiracy
as they like to call him who smuggled
seventy thousand rubber tree seeds out
and now a huge chunk of Southeast Asia
is covered in rubber plantations because
it turns out that even though I learned
in Highland junior high school that
synthetic rubber had you know come up
and save the day in World War two
in fact synthetic rubber isn't very good
and if you want anything for high-tech
purposes or high intensity purposes like
you know that you really want to work
like airplane tires or radial tires or
anything like that they're all made out
of natural rubber natural rubbers 40% of
the market it's still climbing and so
you have an area in Great Britain that
excuse me an area in Southeast Asia it's
roughly the size of Great Britain that
is a single giant rubber plantation and
in Brazil is South American leaf blight
which is to the rubber tree you make
rubber by the way with out of the tree
but you cut it and there's this late SAP
like latex that's in it and you collect
it like maple syrup and you boil it down
to make natural rubber with it there is
in South
America a blight that is to the rubber
tree
what potato blight is to the potato and
we we learn Americans learned about this
when Henry Ford in the 20s bought a huge
spread in the lower Amazon planted
entirely in rubber trees and was wiped
out in months no is he lost a billion
dollars which in you know the 30s was
chained was not was real money I think
yeah and it was the biggest reverse of
his career so it's that organism is
still there and now there's highways all
throughout Southeast Asia the now you
can now drive from Kunming in southern
China all the way to Singapore in three
days and this is known as the blight
highway to the botanists who are freaked
out about it right and I can report from
personal experience that even if you
show up with Brazilian stamps all over
your passport in rubber country they
don't have you know those that you know
how the Food and Agriculture or
inspectors here will spray your shoes
they don't do any of that so the
botanists have been screaming about this
for years and maybe decades and
absolutely nothing is happening so
that's gonna happen how do you think
that plays out it's just just a blight
that takes out the rubber trees what's
kind of interesting there's I mean you
lose the models that I've seen say that
you would lose all of it in three to six
months because it's like an ocean of
breakfast right and so you'd hit would
be the biggest deforestation for a
really long time and so that would have
its own effects and because but now Wade
Davis actually the biologist was the
first to note this folk here now
excellent we have just-in-time
manufacturing and so it used to be you
know in the 50s you would have piles and
piles and piles of tires right right now
you don't you know when you order the
tire they're practically making it
they're on this but they're practically
tapping the tree and making it on the
spot and so the tire Association told me
that there's about a two-week supply so
Wade Davis was on this case he's saying
that this is the end of the auto
industry some particular year or what
he's just saying this is bad and the
extraordinary thing is when he wrote
this I mean there's a bunch of people
have written about this
he wrote memorably about it and so I
thought oh I'm gonna write about this
and I'm gonna talk about how it because
there's this outfit called c-rad which
is the organization of rubber producers
now I'm gonna go there and I'm gonna
find all these great genetic engineering
programs where they're going to breeding
these rubber trees crickets nothing and
so I wrote to them and they it's amazing
but no you think about it though okay I
should not have been surprised I doubt
that there's that many people in this
audience gonna be shocked to find out
that a government-sponsored organization
isn't all that responsive well okay
Ireland if they just brought over a few
more varieties of potato they would've
been helpful yeah so are there not a lot
of varieties of rubber trees these are
all actually I mean it's it's like a
joke but you know Henry Wickham brings
over seventy thousand he doesn't and
he'd they're not properly stored they're
not he's just he's paid by the weight so
he just grabs them all up whether
they're rotten or not and the the brings
because he's paid by the seed and so
they were imagining you know when they
when the British Kew Gardens charges him
with this that he's gonna come over with
half a dozen of these lovingly
probably said he brings three quarters
of a ton and they have about a one
percent germination rate and which even
for an amateur gardener is bad and then
they take them in boats to Sri Lanka and
they're most of them die and so there's
it's very hard to find the exact number
but we'll say six that survived and all
the rubber trees in Southeast Asia not
all but probably like that I haven't
actually checked all but it is what is
thought that a very very very large
percentage of the rubber trees in
Southeast Asia from those six so back in
the clones there's presumably a bit of
variety and and the the trees have a
workaround yeah and in fact by diversity
if you read another Wade Davis book one
River which is a great book um he's a
really good writer so you know the the
US government was very upset when the
Japanese you know took over in World War
two the rubber
so the in addition to developing the
synthetic rubber they sent a guy named
scholtes who is the great botanist from
harvard tropical botanist founder of
ethnobotany just a brilliant guy
interested in drugs and very and he goes
but he's a patriotic druggie and he goes
up and down the Amazon and he collects
hundreds and hundreds of different
rubber trees and they plant them in two
plantations I think Panama and Costa
Rica all over the details and they
defined some that they think are
resistant and then the war ends and the
US government destroys the plantations
because it's a government okay so this
is going to happen I mean it seems well
anyway it's highly unlikely that it's
not yeah okay that would you read her
first yeah a couple of times I got
technical questions one from Jim
Spaulding why didn't the Chinese flood
just uh create big fertile plains in
those rivers well they get 40 feet high
and then they they did and isn't that
become fertile land now well yeah but
there's like you know several hundred
thousand Chinese buried under it and you
know they and so there's a lot more
Chinese who could come in and plant that
land now or yeah I mean it's you know in
some sort of horrible net way it's you
know good for the land but you know if
you're a friend and relative this it's
probably difficult for you to take that
kind of long-term perspective so it does
happen oh yeah yeah and it's the same
thing as in our Mississippi Valley I
mean you know the Katrina was on some
level probably a net echo logical plus
but you know this is not a viewpoint
that is particularly popular in New
Orleans that's interesting I haven't
heard I would like to see an article on
that I don't think I want to be the one
to write it you know in today it's very
easy to find people
Austin asked a question this is
primarily land based modernization
you're talking about what's going on
with the oceans well the big story of
the oceans I mean you guys in San
Francisco and all about its ship ballast
right hmm and here's a here's a case
where there actually has been some
successful action because what starts
with actually probably the first thing
we really understand something about
isn't Chesapeake Bay and you know they
wipe out the tidal areas there and start
growing tobacco like crazy hmm and
tobacco is very heavy so you gotta bring
you know pretty big boats to carry it I
mean the barrel of tobacco it's because
it's wet waste my tongue and and they
they bring in these barrels and so the
ships come back and I mean you know over
there and they you know they whatever
they're bringing is very light compared
to it so they have lots and lots of
ballast and the ballast is made by
taking good English dirt that's right in
the bottom of ship right and in fact I
found aids an 18th century ballast
manual that that tells you where to find
good dirt and stuff like this now it
turns out that most almost all of
northern North America has no need of
earthworms and the reason for this is
they were squished by the ice age and
then for an area south but the glaciers
and so forth and then for an area south
there was permafrost and dude worms
don't like permafrost and earthworms
don't have a lot of get-up-and-go and so
the earthworm specialist I talked to
told me that you know earthworms if you
had a 10 by 10 area or 15 by 15 area an
earthworm would spend its entire life
there so they moved north but really
really slowly okay
and so there's effectively none in
northern parts of North America and so
over thousands of years in fact the
ecosystems in places like Minnesota and
Massachusetts where I live
develop in in their absence and
earthworms are like these tiny engine
you know amazing engineers and so when
Europeans come that ballast savoring it
and then
transporting plants there you know
carrying their own dirt and pretty soon
this earth worms all over the place and
so we're having this sort of slow
experiment to what happens when in areas
evolved without earthworms for thousands
of years and it's you know carried it
carried across the ship ballast now the
same thing is happening in San Francisco
within the waters right okay where
people are because after they start
getting upset about the you know the
dirt being all over the place they start
using balances water and they scoop up
water in China and they bring it over
here and vice versa and the result is
that I think that I think the figure is
almost three-quarters of the species in
San Francisco Bay or non-native so we
have these sort of novels supposedly the
most biologically invaded body of water
there is right it's a total novel you
guys are once a head leading the world
bus hikers on the East Coast can only
marvel at your modernity you know a
couple of weeks ago we vote and we took
it out to Golden Gate celebrate New
Year's a couple months ago and their
harbor porpoises out there there's now
they've been identified they all have
names and they're up to four hundred
these guys have been gone for 40 years
maybe because of agricultural runoff or
who knows what but they're back
which suggests a really healthy
ecosystem in the water out there because
when you get those you know top
predators they've got to feed on your a
bunch of stuff that's coming up the food
chain so those three quarters of alien
invaders have not made the bay unhealthy
and until you know there's sort of
unfortunate we have this varies invaders
because the great majority of them are
perfectly benign you know and the ones
that are problematic are not problematic
because they're immigrants but they're
problematic azar problematic you know I
have native species that are you know
pains in the neck and they and so you
know we have this idea of these pristine
ecosystems and that great geographer
William Donovan is you know calls us the
pristine myth
that we have this idea of these
ecosystems as these you know untouched
permanent entities that go through these
you know beautiful stages of succession
and you know or whole and self-contained
and it really doesn't work like that
what's what's happened is that this kind
of natural mixing is a phase we've
served turned it up to 11
you know spinal tap reference right and
there's there's reason to wish that
maybe we turn it back down to like eight
you know yeah well I mean you can
imagine it's gonna be tough to get in
eradicate the earthworm you know maybe
not even bearable but it is but you know
there are things they could the Robbins
alone are gonna complain yeah people
like the Robbins in right but you know
it's like sugar maples are disappearing
from former sugar maple for us because
when they're little the sugar maple sap
things have these roots that because
they're you when you don't have worms
what they do is there's leaf litter you
know that the leaves fall down in the
soil all right and basically earthworms
are machines that eat all that stuff
right and go down into the soil and
excrete it in the form of worm castings
enrich the soil enrich the soil but if
you're in an free area all the plants
have these little root like threads that
go into the pile of leaf litter above
the soil and especially littler plants
and so when the worms go they they're
incredibly efficient they can wipe out
this leaf litter in months in a matter
of months and then all these plants
don't you know they you know a plant
can't say oh I guess the food is down
here now you know it just futile he
tries to feed itself where it's going to
so you're seeing a wholesale replacement
of certain types of vegetation so
engineer some maple trees to make sugar
bushes that know about you know or the
other approach is there's the various
bands of kind of admirable people who
are trying to fight the worm invasion
there's the minnesota worm watch by
pulling them up feeding into fish but
they put up signs like you know
fishermen please you know don't you know
in addition to taking out your trash
take out your worms and Alberta is
trying to has a program to teach
you know elementary school kids about
the evils of warmth and I'm not kidding
just goes to show you talk more about
this is looks like Candace you talk more
about the European Ice Age and its
causation there's a paleo climatologist
named Ruddiman nice yes yes Kermit was
the first guy to point this out and as
he seemed late was kind of kind of
virtual when he said yes change egg was
two separate parts of his um his theory
and he wrote a book I think it's called
plows plagues in petroleum you got him
right and it's also quite interesting
it's not long sounds good
and he argues that that this in effect I
mean he came out before my book but he
effectively argues that this man guy is
all wet that the homogeneous scene and
the Anthropocene all these things really
began with the invention of agriculture
and we have been having a dramatic
impact on the climate since agriculture
which involves you know clearing huge
forests and and so if we're actually
literally changing the albedo of the
planet but there's these dips in when
the in in the past actually it sort of
worked out as I understand it that the
increasing temperature rise as more or
less canceled out would have been a
natural cooling trend and this is why
climatologist were confused and Roper
wrote in the 60s and 70s that we should
be heading for an ice age because
normally we would be but you know we've
been but late lately or our balance has
gotten off and we're no longer just
cancelling a natural effect were you
know going off into all kinds of effects
that you know are far beyond the scope
of a great there's no more ice agent
right so the early the climate change
thing that the Little Ice Age so there's
an arguments about whether agriculture
really had that much effect the
particular thing I'm talking about is
the Little Ice Age and there's three
main theories for why the Little Ice Age
would cost one is sunspots and there's
this period of time called the maunder
minimum and basically I don't think
anybody believes that anymore
it's pretty there's a couple papers that
sort of trash that the second one is
that there is these volcanoes and that
there is this 250 year run of volcanoes
and that could happen because you know
the volcanoes put stuff in the air and
then it before it's done before you know
what Krakatoa said on the year without
the summer and that sort of stuff in
1815 but you'd have to have 250 years of
volcanoes and there's just doesn't seem
to be records of enough volcanoes and so
this theory has hit the skids of it
although it was recently somebody tried
to resurrect it by saying that well it
seems to me kind of like hand waving
that you know they said well maybe
there's these other effects and so this
is the main theory that's left standing
that I'm sure the authors of the paper
wouldn't like to hear it described a way
question from somebody nameless why
didn't the Africans die of the Eurasian
diseases the way the Native Americans
did so yeah well they were all Europeans
came over they've been living with all
these animals they came by they had all
these diseases and they were also
colonizing an Africa where Africans
dying from those European diseases to to
to a small extent but basically most of
those diseases existed in Africa because
you know all those areas are connected
and so you had smallpox and TB and you
know all those kind of diseases existed
in most of Africa the big changes across
the Pacific and across the across the
Atlantic okay John Willis asks what is
your take on the native plant movement
which I'm a member of I rip up all kinds
of invasive alien invasive plants that I
don't like like I guess I'm I like them
I think it's you know people are the
plants the plants advance I mean I think
it's neat that you know we are we're you
know well I guess my attitude is
inconsistent like pretty much everybody
else's we have you know we're building a
house and so we're landscaping it right
now and we want to landscape it in New
England plants because that's sort of
cool and it also there's something about
a sense of place and so forth but in
fact we also were planting cherry trees
because they're like cherry trees and
you know churches have nothing to do
with New England right and peach trees
are also invasive actually they're peach
trees when they're introduced to Georgia
were so invasive that
that it was called a wilderness of peach
trees and people are trying to cut them
down or they were being choked out it's
kind of a precursor to kudzu yeah what a
peach trees replace so longer we don't
know they're all gone there okay well
there were these empty areas that that
native people had cultivated and you
have the peach trees rushing into a
Heather succession plan there a
succession plan yeah well and the cool
one was Darwin writes about this and
that he would he saw a huge force of
artichoke in Argentina that we're making
the Pampas and you know impossible to
pass through and people you know cursing
the artichokes and then their reports of
gigantic fields of arugula and in Peru
there are a wriggle enthusiast like my
wife it would probably like to go I
think they're beating it away with a
stick Alex asks how magis do you think
the earth can really get into say the
next next 500 years pretty much ins okay
but you know there's obviously mostly
done or halfway along or what would you
say you know it's sort of hard to say we
don't even know how many species are out
right yeah well you yeah yeah yeah I'm
probably heard I'm sure it will Centauri
talked about the you know the enormous
ignorance so we know if maybe 1.3
million species of this and he thinks
you know millions upon millions more
right so what percentage of those people
those endemic guys in yeah but a lot of
them can move around right you know
kudzu was endemic to Japan and now if
you've been to the southeast it's
definitely not endemic to Japan mm-hmm
so that would be that would you know so
the moisture got more kudzu to come do
you think I I think there's gonna be war
I mean what are the odds that you know
given that we don't even have a clue as
to how many species there are that all
of them from everywhere have gotten to
where they're their final destination it
just seems very unlikely to me so
somewhat overlapping to this is if you
mind talking to this audience a little
bit about the book you're working on now
sure I guess I don't really saw I was
very tricky but I think it's less tricky
with nonfiction than with fiction yes
this is a
ah you were working well the problem the
real problem for me is that I don't
really have an elevator speech you know
that's right just hold forth what's it
about hold forth I'm you know my heart
sinks as imagining these people here
hearing words for to make people know
start with two people so anyway so book
about the future that makes no
predictions okay without predicting like
that yeah this is a book that stays in
print yeah well you know I mean you know
begin with there all those books about
the future to make for the Britons are
wrong they're always wrong and then you
know the author looks like an idiot so
but at the same time the idea is that
you know I have a you know some kids and
I was looking at them I'm thinking you
know when they're my age there's gonna
be between nine and ten billion people
in the world which is a lot right and
and when you talk to people like
agronomists and water specialists like
Peter gleich and those guys they're very
worried about how we're all gonna manage
this and it's a severe technical
challenge
you know they because not only are there
all these people they actually the
number of people is less important than
the fact that one of the big changes in
our lifetime has been that huge numbers
of people in Asia and Latin America have
been lifted out of you know really dire
poverty when I went to Highland junior
high school about 40 percent of the
world was you know hungry or not quite
getting adequate nutrition or you know
much worse and now it's about seven
percent I mean that's like an incredible
thing right um
I mean you know we live in a time where
this so that's a huge demographic event
it you think it's a huge ecological
event well yeah because you know when
you're wealthier you want to eat better
you know you don't want your parents
cruel you know if you're really at the
edge you'll eat gruel but you you know
you'd like a Snickers bar you'd like an
occasional treat you like a burger and
of course you would I would you would
and so you know what this translates is
that people with who you know spend a
lot time thinking about this argue that
roughly speaking by 2050 we're gonna
need to come up with forty percent more
cereal crops forty percent more grain
forty percent more grain 50 yeah okay
which is a lot right because it's not
exactly there's off because popular yes
populations low-level off and you know
all this is kind of squishy but the idea
but you know some you know it's still a
lot and it makes make sort of intuitive
sense so how you gonna do this you know
and there's two main approaches which
are associated with these two guys I'm
least in my mind and they're the two I
told you this was like now start with
vote okay well there's these two guys
said I think are the most important
people in the 20th century for the 21st
century if you follow and they are
terribly pretty important at the 2007
for the next century I think because
they embody the two sort of broadly
speaking the two main approaches and one
guy and neither of them anybody's heard
of which is like good and bad right um
because it's not specialized that on
your books you're full of news for
people I didn't know stuff and these
other things I like that I like that I'm
gonna have to tell my publisher this is
not a book about two people you've
nobody's ever heard of but it's full of
news good um you heard that right
really does it this is right anyway so
there's this one one guy who's the first
guy who wrote a sort of modern we're all
going to hell book his name was william
vote look at the dead silence right as
anybody in this room i heard of him
william vote vog t and then he inspired
the art plundered planet guy yeah our
plunder planet guy and he's he oh I knew
you're gonna say I can't remember at the
moment anyway both of them inspired Paul
Ehrlich who heard Paul Ehrlich but you
know he was the guy who put into print
Aldo Leopold he basically wrote Aldo
Leopold stuff cuz Leopold was a
brilliant guy but not really that much
of a writer the sand County Almanac
which was put together after his death
by boat if I vote Wow he got Rachel
Carson into print he inspired the
Population Bomb he was the director of
the population council he was the you
know major force and founder of zero
population growth there's this guy named
Hugh Moore who he basically dragged in
and became the founder of the funder of
all these things and so he did all these
things
but he was the first guy in book called
the road to survival which is published
in the 40s to do the modern version of
Malthusian ISM which is Malthus said
that basically we grow more food we have
we have more babies the babies eat the
food we go back to the same level of
misery right vote said no no we're gonna
grow enough food but in doing so we're
gonna trash the ecosystems on which we
depend it's a very different approach
that the you know in feeding us in
supplying our demands we're gonna wreck
stuff and so he was the first person to
say we need to cut back you know the the
Al Gore approach you know the the the
Jimmy Carter where's wear a cardigan
sweater approach you know turn down the
thermostat reduce the human footprint
don't eat meat this is late 40s after
the war he's saying let's cut back yeah
oh good luck with that well actually he
was there's a lot of fifties I mean yeah
yeah but no actually a lot of people
listen because true my mother wasn't
yeah your mother was no no no it's very
you know and it was very much you know
he was he also very important in the
Audubon Society he was one of the
founders of the breeding bird census I
mean the guy was all over the place
really a remarkable guy and as human
interest he did all this while having
polio and so he you know went all over
the world on a wheelchair and so he's
you know a gutsy guy and his he hated
the other guy as far as we can tell and
his name is Norman Borlaug I but she's
some of you heard his name yeah yeah and
Borlaug in addition to being the guy who
started the Green Revolution was kind of
the apotheosis of the idea in the that
we have these environmental problems we
have you know they're serious using
science and technology we can produce
our way out of them mmm-hmm and the
Green Revolution is case but he was also
a major force from nuclear power he was
a big backer of genetic inches actually
was a force for nuclear power yeah also
well he was amazed he what he did was he
knew these people you see him constantly
you know pushing nuclear power in
environmental organizations saying don't
fight nuclear power don't fight nuclear
power well this would be of interest to
you I would imagine yeah know that and
so he didn't listen to it no didn't
listen to him his world
address you know talks about the need
for for you know clean safe sources of
energy you know so he uses his weight
he'd and there's also a major backer of
genetic engineering one of his last
projects is this pride project that we
were talking about before the attempt to
put to change the way photosynthesis
works in rice to make it more productive
say a little more about this and there's
an amazing project done by this outfit
called the International Rice Research
Institute outside of Manila an
incredible place in the place that you
know really brought the Green Revolution
to to rice and there's an international
collaboration that started in 2009 the
year Borlaug's death by the way bearing
in mind that half of all humanity eats
right right staple and there's four
different types of photosynthesis I
believe that's the number still and
there's a lot of argument about how they
different involved and the basic thing
is that they're all horribly inefficient
there's like the worst most inefficient
chemical reaction you can imagine you
know as a friend of mine said it's like
proof of the existence of God because no
human would have no real human would
have come up with something so bad you
sort of make sense right stupid design
yeah yeah stupid design anyway the there
is some of it however is less
inefficient and that's called c4 and
that's one of the reasons that corn is
so incredibly productive who grows these
huge stalks as it has a slightly more
efficient version of photosynthesis than
rice sugar cane g4 yes okay it grows
like crazy right and so I think it is
yeah and does anybody know we think
sugar came to c4 right if we're wrong
yeah so I thought oh good okay I was I
suddenly thought you know there's people
in the audience who will know this yes
in this kind of crowd right so I can't
just get away with the blather than yeah
thank you thank you thank you you if I
said anything else wrong
there's a certain amount of where do we
start but yeah anyway the idea is that
you can transplant this mechanism that
into rice and it won't alter in theory
the the flavor of the rice or the way
race what we'll do is make it grow
faster and you might get another crop in
in there and you could put a you know
soybeans or something in there that
would replenish the soil and you could
you know boost agricultural productivity
this is fundamental stuff we're talking
about changing the nature of the
material doesn't think it's more
fundamental than that you know and so
this whole thing like the flavor saver
tomato you know and all these other
things it just seems like yeah we're
going deep well what it what's the
current reading that he was working on
see for rice is it looked likely or what
the you know I've just begun researching
this but the so all I can tell you is
that the researchers feel very
optimistic so Norman Borlaug and vote
often did they know they didn't know you
know the the basic idea said you know
for the book is to take you know for
real serious areas which rather cheese
leo I think of as the four elements
you know earth air fire water and so
Earth is a lazy yeah it is horrible I
may not do it because I mean I'm gonna
cover those four areas but it's so yeah
it's pretty bad but it worked as a sales
thing and look part of the elevator
pitch that I had and he looked he just
trashed it yeah leave out the four Greek
element yeah well made okay you heard
here guys it's on it's gone okay
but the anyway the idea is that there is
AG recover you know how we're gonna feed
all these people there's water and
there's a high-tech you know version of
that which is these massive desalination
plants which are by nuclear power run by
nuclear power which you're seeing in
places like North East China and then
there's you know energy supplies and
then climate change which is sort of odd
man out but it also plays a role in all
this because and the idea is that
there's a Borlaug en path like you know
in waters case that would be curious
China's trying to embrace both as water
because intention there rewind which is
this huge city they're rewiring the
whole city re plumbing the whole city to
have gray water in every apartment which
is costing you know eleventy billion
dollars and and so and of course the
deal is that yes china's discovery you
really can't do both you know the you
know they're both of these approaches
the you know for logging the voting
approach or in fact yeah you may know
that we feed drinking water to or
agriculture right excellent
you know at vast expense yeah energy and
everything else and i think there's a
good argument for lighting the gray
water or less right incredibly pristine
water period basically going out there
the acres and acres yeah i have to say
that is that when i was in my first time
i came to in real visit to california
and I'm driving along the Central Valley
and I'm seeing these swimming pools and
you know 106 degrees and I'm driving
with my friend Peter Mansell the
photographer and I said what's that he
says rice and I just like know they're
growing rice in the desert get real
turned out to be good for the birds
because they figured out a way the
Cadillac Ranch guy and figured out that
you know actually the dry part of season
and bring the birds in they poop you
know instant guano that you don't pay
for a lot of advantages actually to some
of the especially in northern Cal no
anyways agriculture still fly hundred
sixty Croatian guys work together 106
degrees vast amounts of really good
water there's that so China is great
watering a city and you can't really do
it turns out there's a practical matter
is very hard to do both because the
people in the great water say or said
wait a minute you're charging me to like
redo all this stuff my apartment and
over there they have fresh water from
salinization
and the people who are doing the
salinization and said wait a minute why
are they doing the gray water you know
what that money should go to us both
were saying that money should go to us
and so I would argue us in most places
as a practical matter you're gonna tend
towards one part of the spectrum worthy
or the other and that
you know my children your children are
going to you know ultimately that's
gonna be the decision that they already
made you have a name for these two
paradigms yet well I called them I'm
afraid to tell you because you're gonna
say it's terrible
and I don't have a I'm so in awe of your
books that don't pay no attention this
is like the soft soap I mean it's so
naked it's when I borrow something I
can't help it out oh man
so anyway the two paradigms have they
obviously voting and borlaug in which is
terrible but right sort of the title of
the book tentatively is is is the wizard
and the Prophet the wizard and the
Prophet what do you say this is I can
take this little part and send it to my
editor got a subtitle yeah no okay um
it's actually pretty good cuz I can even
tell who is who
mmm so play out a volte inversion of of
this century I got it I think I have a
pretty good idea of what you're gonna do
yeah mainly cuz it's sort of what I
would want to do yeah but I used to be
over in the VOC in view of things
because my teacher Paul air like in
Varese are the things that I bought from
my fellow environmentalists incorrectly
and so I could see the borlaug in thing
coming along more and more engineers in
the world blah blah blah the developing
world developing among other things a
lot of really smart people with really
good training who have their own
agricultural issues water issues and so
on and they're not running their
engineering ideas through us anymore
they're doing them right there when they
live and they don't worry about things
you worry about so we'll talk about I
guess I think of it I mean again this is
something I'm researching but I think
there you can think of it as week vote
and strong vote weak vote is kind of
like you don't stop eating meat you know
and then pull out your canines for me
yeah well you can't and then you know
and there's a factor it's just a op-ed
in the New York Times last week I think
big deal you know where someone said
that essentially meat is just
unsustainable in any way that's true on
the Ilia so vote would say stopping is
something that's that's the week for him
now at the other and Borlaug would say
the grow meat and vats grow meat and
baths but you know it's the curious
thing is there so does pet up by the way
pedis is that ya know I went actually
went over there to the Netherlands which
is a center of that a couple months ago
and you know there this is a project
that could clearly happen it's because
it's tissue
so yeah the weird thing is that they
just can't get funding this is like a
Kickstarter project right that's all
they said they just can't get funding
and there you know is this not but the
other approach is that you sort of
rethink agriculture itself and that
cereal agriculture green agriculture is
but is you know it has it's not suitable
for every place um its and there's a lot
of places where we worry do it which not
you know especially you know the
smartest way to go about it and there
are other models of agra agra forestry
and always yeah trees and tubers and
trees and tubers trees and tubers and
there's a lot of research on this and
it's just stupefyingly productive the
question is whether you could really
mechanize it and in i you know it's a
lot of issues with that I tend to think
more clever and truffles pretty soon
you're right if you can sniff a truffle
you can probably pick a tree and there
you get you know because what you have
is these systems tend to replicate
natural systems you have some advantages
and you're doing kind of multi cropping
it at once and that robots with Syrah
peas and yeah
and that connect you know that so
there's a weird way you know again
that's something but there's a fair
number of people very smart people in
places like Brazil I think that this is
the you know this is though is though is
the way to go and that you could have
extraordinarily productive farms without
going through this very complicated
procedure that they're doing in Erie
which is they regard you know in the
sort of voting way as trying to you know
ring the last drops out of an exhausted
paradigm first population growth fit in
all of this it says I far as I can tell
you know there's this is a time when
there's a little bit of Neil Malthusian
ISM in the air you have things like
there's been reports of forced
sterilization coming up again where
India but of who by who
I don't really there's an article in The
Guardian about it a couple weeks ago so
you know and there's a woman who named
Betsy Hartman at at Hampshire College
who's really the expert on this and
basically what I know is from her just
says said you know this is like you know
she said I thought we had gotten rid of
this in the seventies hidden yeah and
it's it's back and she believes that you
know I'm really just taking it from her
so I haven't really independently
verified to this but she believes that
you know in the NGO world it's all back
you know not unless you know it's it's
or no no it's coming back it's coming
back and her folks it's really good on
that by the way is Fred Pierce's the
coming population collapse right called
people quake and no it's complicated
because you know all societies have
depended on this population structure we
have lots and lots of young people and a
small number of older people and that's
kind of how the Social Security and and
all that is the assumption is that
there's all these younger people who are
kicking in their pennies to support a
small number of older people but you
know people like you and me are hanging
around for far too long and the we're
not having enough babies and so the
instead of being a triangle you know
pyramid as it's called isn't looking
more like this no society ever has
looked like this before so there is that
is a genuine change and you have you
know if they live if you know people
like you and me keep you know don't kick
the bucket enough we we end up with
things like you know you know these
endlessly hanging around people like you
know can you imagine Donald Trump at 160
years old
how about Edward / Wilson nerd 160 I
would I would settle for that well I
know but the question is the Edward
Wilson 160 count cancelled the through
Donald Trump when his fortune is
multiplied through the magic of compound
interest number of this audience heard
ed Wilson Friday night and I think you
read his book on your way here yeah and
so this group would probably be
interested to know what you make of Ed
Wilson and the social conquest of Earth
[Music]
and I have a complicated relationship ah
well I mean not not an important one to
him in any way but I wrote a when he
started coming out with the biodiversity
stuff I wrote an article in science
about because I'm of course mind for
science about that the math and the
science behind the biodiversity crisis
very shaky mmm-hmm which it is hot spots
have sort of gone away
well it just it's it's all based on
there's a there's a guy named Peters in
the 90s he wrote a thing called a
critique for ecology which he lambaste
city ecologists for not really being
rigorous and unfortunately it's still
quite true
and and then I don't know then we go I
wrote a review of Concilium which I
argued that he starts from as he did
with sociobiology starts from this
incredibly solid base and the insect
Kingdom but he's a little bit like he's
inching along a branch until I gets to
the very end at which point he saws off
the branch and falls to the ground with
a large crash
and so you know he he is essentially
saying the entire world is like social
insects and I am making by analogy
people that is in with this book yet you
social people are like you social and
it's only not yeah and it's it's it's
like an analogy which is a really
powerful analogy but I don't know if
it's actually science do you buy a group
selection multi-level selection I don't
know I just read the book you know and
so I'd have to read again but I looked
in there I said wow that's really
interesting
but I don't get I couldn't find where he
specified the exact mechanism by which
would happen and he said it's sort of it
seemed to me the same but maybe I'm
wrong okay because I said I read on a
plane we did not you know really
conducive to thought I kept saying well
how does this happen exactly you know
I'm like the I don't have much
imagination I always want to know
where's he's saying it happens how and
he kept it seemed to me but could be
wrong that he was sort of saying what
happens cuz look this it must have
happened but if say no no how you know
it's not enough to say it must have you
want to say how yeah it's kind of like
the Gaia hypothesis where basically
James Lovelock was saying well you know
we're not like Mars and we're not like
Venus so the end result suggests that
where you really have life you have the
sulfur yeah I wrote a piece about that
for science or saying about how exactly
how hydrogen sulfide looked pretty good
at seeing those coming out of the
microbes in the ocean so you know thank
you problets would make clouds freezing
maybe the way to put it is that this is
not a book for the very literal-minded
like me uh-huh
excellent so this conversation will
continue so
he's long credibly nice man I have to
say I feel uncomfortable in this because
he's it just an extraordinary decent guy
and he's been terrifyingly right a lot
of time oh yeah we're poke pickin on the
you know is it's unfair and as a natural
scientist sees without pure is for the
answer
um your book the new one of the wizard
and the prophet the unwritten and I'm
research book yeah is talking about the
whole century or 2050 like everybody
does or what what's the timeframe well
I'm a little bit vague about that cuz
it's unwritten and unresearched but I
think that the the point is it's
probably this coming century it's that
it's you know I mean you know to attempt
to imagine what things are going to be
like in a hundred years seems you know
at the very edge of possibility but you
you could probably get thirty years you
know well the kinds of biases that you
did research and did write very well
about that in these two books 1491 Oh
1493 what was the pace of change of
those events some fast some slow see a
little bit about each and why well I
mean well the big example would be the
the smallpox
you know smallpox camión and that was
the very fast killer and there's a kind
of like the comes in apparently in 1519
comes to the American mainland there's
some records that was brought in by a
African slave named Francisco Agia
historian I talked to things that this
is Spanish malarkey and that they just
don't want to cop to the fact that they
brought it themselves so they bring him
it on an African and it's theirs so this
is all quite clear in the records and
there's an interesting thing actually
demonstrating the importance of disease
to the European conquest of the Americas
you know Cortes comes before this
alright and he does this thing that the
Spaniards have learned in the islands
which is you seize the king and this
would have worked in Europe by the way
if a party of Inca had somehow come to
France and seize the Sun King and you
know it the court would
paralyzed for months in the same way the
same thing would happen in Stalin right
and so this is a novel I want somebody
to write yeah but what were alternative
history yeah it would have worked it
would have worked and worked in you know
because the Chinese guys know this big
ship screwed on it yeah Chinese guys and
their ships could have done exactly and
they so they see how it was the previous
speaker of why the West rules for now
more aimed more at Morris any really
interesting book yeah
so the so he sees the king and it does
as it would have done in most places in
the world paralyzes the court for a few
months and then they sort of regroup
they say wait a minute there's just a
few hundred of these guys and there's
like 18 billion of us even though the
king is divinely appointed okay do math
yeah do the math and so they attacked
the Spaniards and they they kicked
Cortes his ass that's a technical term
I'm using here and they do with guys
with you know guns and swords of steel
yeah but horses and stuff that just only
the kill all the horses a wipeout I
think is about two-thirds of the
Spaniards and supposedly is in Spanish
history that's called the noche triste
it's then that sad night it's a great
night if you're not Spanish
supposedly Cortez you know he escapes
and sits under the tree is some tree and
cries at the ruination of his hopes so
then did he still have the girlfriend
that had helped him get yeah yeah yeah
she got away and and so it's a really
good story yeah and there's no weirdly
enough there's really no good account of
it that takes together because there's
these were literate societies and
there's tons of native sources about it
written you know in language but there's
nothing that's really tries to combine
that the two of them the closest is an
academic study quite a good one by a guy
named hosik but there's nothing that's
really meant for ordinary people
anyway the sweet Christ and then he is
an amazing guy Cortes heat starts all
over again
and basically what he's done is foam
into civil war everybody hates the
Aztecs um so he
he manages to gin up this colt he's a
better he's a tremendous politician
yu-jin's up this coalition so he's you
know it's he's writing at the head of an
army of tens of thousands of people
local people local people right what
he's doing he in this very clever way he
foments a civil war and hijacks it
themselves in charge both sides exhaust
themselves but what happens is you know
he's lost while he's gathering together
the second time the smallpox comes in
and untreated smallpox kills about 40
percent of the people get it so this is
one the most densely parted place
populated parts of the earth and forty
percent of the people died including
most of the court and in Tenochtitlan
and the Spaniards are all mutant and so
they draw from this their immunity you
know pretty clearly well God must like
us right and the Indians draw the same
lesson because they see the span here's
your immune right they think God must
not like us it's a tremendous
psychological boost and they're able to
take it and they wiped out court and
goes to victory so you have an
experiment there anyway this was no
Joseph Nye the other guy the other day
the guy who there's a soft power right
and he says narrative is everything easy
and sequence drives narrative mm-hmm and
this was a case where you know this
biological event occurred right then you
had these two mirror narratives right
came up the same time and then that
happened in the 60s they traced this
epidemic and it raised all the way
through Central America and again
there's records of it when Spaniards had
come and they'd find all these people
who'd had smallpox and say how long ago
was that there was ten years ago and you
know because he's and went into the Inca
Empire which is again this hugely
populous central society and it wiped
out the killed the Emperor killed a
bunch of his chosen successor you know
killed a bunch of the people in the in
the court and led to a civil war you
know over the succession that Pizarro
was able to walk into and hijack there
you go and so you have incur any way to
there's an incredibly long winded answer
to your question would you know there's
very fast-paced
this case well it spread virally as we
say yeah um smallpox is a virus yeah so
are YouTube videos so let's end with
what's the case of a slower
equally powerful kind of change that
happens in this homogeneous ation of
everything well I would say that one of
these sort of big unknown stories of the
spread of African grasses afraid of
African grasses throughout the Americas
these incredibly tough grasses and one
of the things that we're learning is
that these grasses are these very same
kinds of grass and you know a big puzzle
you know to me at least when I went to
the Amazon saw these areas they've been
cleared for ranches and then they're
abandoned and so all that stuff that
people say is completely true how
terrible it is well why aren't the
forestry growing yeah because we knew
they'd regroup because the areas that
were wiped out by the rubber trade have
done fine well a lot of the reason is
that when the farmers deliberately
planted African grasses like what what
kind of grass is easier of grazing
grasses these are grazing grasses out
yeah and I think Judy carne attila and
UCLA has written a lot about this
there's a bunch of people written about
african grasses in the in the new world
and they were initially came to the
caribbean in the bedding of slave ships
and and so forth and they are these
thick spongy cover that chokes off
regrowth and so they've been a very very
effective me doesn't prevent savannah
like you see in parts of africa mm-hmm
doesn't permit a savanna of why they're
spaced trees no no no they they're their
will they burn they cut down everything
and they plant you know some types of
these are short grass and not the tall
ones and and they are having a big big
impact slowly spreading into forests
this natural disturbances occur in the
African grasses colonize it there you go
carries on to this day
more to come and to hold different kinds
of solution sets that is going
this next book thank you for coming
tonight thank you
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
you